- Very nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure, my guy.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Rob] Great, man.
(hip hop music)
It's confirmation.
It's like the stuff that
you already maybe knew
in your gut--
- 100%
- What you were pushing toward,
it's like, okay, I'm not the
only one who feels like this.
I'm not crazy.
I saw you write about some
people I know, Deon Graham,
is someone who I've known
and worked with a bit.
It was dope.
It's great to have it as
a resource, as a reminder
that you're not the only one in the world
who feels like this.
- I totally agree.
I think affirmation is like ...
You know?
- Yeah.
To me, I always just think if
you get one nuance it's gold,
you know?
- Right.
So what's going on?
- Nothing, man, just working, man.
I'm trying to balance it,
the passion and the business
and not lose yourself in it
and love every minute.
- How's it going?
- Great.
- Good.
So far, so good.
- When did it start, a couple months ago?
- I started about last year,
I started with the music.
I've been doing journalism--
- Well, I know, the
Genius work and all that?
- Yeah, but I started the music last year.
We were actually supposed to meet ...
I don't know if you remember
this, we were supposed to meet
last year and Mike was
trying to set it up,
and I had to cancel--
- Because you were making the transition.
- Yeah, well what happened
was Logic called me.
He had sold out at the Barclay's and said,
"Yo, do you wanna come on stage with me?"
- And you were like, yeah!
(laughing)
- I didn't wanna cancel but I said ...
- Nah man, that was the right cancel.
I would fucking cancel that.
- Yeah, man.
- That's amazing.
- I was in the crowd, I saw it.
I saw him bring you out.
- Yeah.
- You made the right choice.
I mean, that was a packed house--
- What do you mean he
made the right choice?
You're my guy.
- He doesn't even wanna
perform his song, man.
- 100%, that's huge.
- Such a moment--
- Yeah.
- How'd it feel?
- It felt great because I'm
from Flatbush Brooklyn--
- Now I'm aware.
- My place is right
there on Flatbush Avenue.
- That's crazy, you
must've been just like,
what the fuck, huh?
- It wasn't even there when I was a kid.
Imagine if when you're
a kid somebody says,
yo, we're gonna take Madison Square Garden
and put it right on Flatbush Avenue
and all your favorite
artists will perform there--
- And you'll perform there.
That's just crazy.
- I used to battle on that corner
of Flatbush and Atlantic
Avenue because I went to school
at Brooklyn Tech.
On the way home from school--
- Who's the person that
roasted you the most
in the history of your
life on that corner?
- We know him.
It wasn't on that corner.
Nobody roasted me on that corner.
I was good.
I definitely used to battle
and there's an emcee,
people know him, I don't
know if you heard of him.
His name is The Immortal Technique.
- Yes, destroyed you?
- He destroyed me.
- He had his day and you
didn't have your day?
It's like a boxing match.
- No, at the time, he
was just better than me.
- Period.
- It's just period what it was.
- Yeah, you got it.
You just went up in weight class.
- Yeah.
- How'd you feel?
- When I lost?
- Yeah.
- I mean,
it stung but I knew he was better than me.
- Yeah, you were looking for the upset.
- Yeah, I wasn't salty.
Well, what happened was
I didn't have a choice.
When you're challenging and you're there
and people were watching.
We were in a club called The
Wetlands, it doesn't exist
anymore, but we're in
the basement of this club
and everybody's watching.
Well, you gotta go for it.
- 100%, because the
alternative's way worse.
- Yeah.
- Getting knocked out
is a helluva lot worse
than leaving the ring.
A lot better, excuse me.
- The one lesson that I
did learn because he and I
were friends before that and so I laughed.
It was fun to me.
- You took it too light.
- He took it seriously.
- I get it.
I'm the same--
- I saw the look in his eyes.
- He would kill me in that moment.
- That's so funny, all
my friends growing up
always would say that about
me when we would play things.
- Right.
- I literally thought a
backyard basketball game
was fucking Roman Empire,
like if I lose this game
one-on-one, I'd die.
- Right.
- That's how I do everything still.
I get that.
That makes a lot of sense to me, man.
- But what I found is in my
career of journalism, I approach
it very much the same way.
When I'm creating content,
when I'm doing something
with an artist, I want the best interview,
I want the best content--
- That's exactly right.
If blah, blah, blah had the
best interview ever, you're like
fuck that.
I'm gonna get something out of this guy
that he's never said before.
- And guess what?
This is real and I believe it.
I had the best Kendrick
Lamar interview ever.
You know what I'm saying?
I had the best 21 Savage interview ever.
This is how I feel and I dare anybody
to say something different or do better--
- The one where you took
him to Sharp with the knives
and everything.
- Yeah, we took 21 Savage,
I took him to a blacksmith
with Genius and our team took him,
and he has the knife tattoo on his head
and we recreated the knife tattoo
into an actual knife, got an
actual blacksmith to do it
and through that we had
a conversation about
what the tattoo means to him,
him growing up, why he
raps the way he raps.
- Look, you're a storyteller.
- Right.
It's funny that you realize
that when I made the transition,
the thing was I grew up
and I always used to rap.
I thought I was gonna be a rapper first.
The problem was I had my first son.
- How old?
- My son is 12 now.
Were you?
You.
- Oh, me, I'm 38.
- Right.
- And rap wasn't paying the bills
and journalism came knocking
and I was like, I'm not
turning this check down,
I got bills to pay, I got mouths to feed.
When I got into the industry,
I still would do music
but I was made to feel like
I was doing something wrong.
You couldn't be a journalist
and do music at the same time--
- You're preaching.
- I literally was almost fired--
- While you're distracted.
- Because they didn't understand it.
And when it came time to choose the music
which was the passion or the
money and paying the bills ...
- You took the money.
- I had to.
- My man, everybody does.
Why do you think the people that don't
get put on a pedestal?
- Yeah and I was just afraid
and I wasn't afraid for me--
Of course.
My guy, of course.
- But what happens is now ...
- And there's a million
versions of that story.
- Absolutely.
- There's a person that
decides to go rob somebody
and goes to jail for three years.
There's a million versions of that story.
The reason the person that
doesn't choose those paths,
goes and is one of the few
people that gets through,
is put on a pedestal, it's
because 99% don't even try
and 99% of the 1% don't make it.
- Right.
But what happened to me was
I was good at journalism.
- Because it was the same fucking game.
- Right, and this is what I realized
because it's storytelling
and going back to the point
that you said, it's all storytelling.
Now, I get to a point
in my journalism career
where I'm at Genius and the
day that I joined Genius,
every rapper worth talking
about was tweeting about me
moving to Genius.
Meek Mill had tweeted about
it and this was three days
after Back to Back.
He wasn't on Twitter for those
three days but he tweeted
to say, yo, congratulations,
Rob, congratulations, Genius.
This is dope.
- That's so great, man,
that's so fucking awesome.
- What I realized at that point was
it's time to follow the passion.
- Even right then and there?
- Maybe not at that moment--
- But that became the seed.
- First of all, I'm at
a point in journalism
where nobody's gonna
fire me for making music.
Really what it came down to was
I had accomplished everything in my life.
I accomplished more
than I thought I could--
- In that field.
- Yeah, but in life at this point.
- Yeah, I get it.
- More than I thought I
could, more than I think a lot
of people gave me credit
for when I was growing up.
But I didn't wanna look
back at my life and not do
the one thing that I always wanted to do
which was make music.
- Honestly, I think the biggest confusion
of the way people consume my content is
I believe in the way that
you did it more than the way
that people interpret what
I'm telling them to do is.
People hear the part of my
content that says go jump,
quit your job.
They don't hear the practical part.
- Right.
- They didn't hear the other
part of the sentence which was
if you're willing to live
in a shittier situation
in the short term ...
You could've made the jump,
but you and your girl and your baby
would've had it even shittier.
You coulda.
You didn't have to take a check from XXL.
You coulda kept going.
- And the check wasn't that big.
- That's right, you coulda
worked at the fucking--
- We rectified that, baby.
- But you coulda worked at the bodega.
You coulda.
You coulda fucking played Cee-Lo
in the corner, try to win.
You coulda.
You could have moved in with your moms.
You could have.
- Right.
- They hear the jump.
They don't hear the but
everything else besides the jump
is about to get worse.
The 22 year olds hear me say,
yo, this is the practical time
to jump.
All these kids that are shitting
on their parents because
of my content don't hear
the part that I agree
with their parents on
which is wait, oh, kid
who I just paid college
for, you're telling me
some fucking asshole
Gary V on the Internet
said don't get a job and now
you're gonna be a rapper?
Cool, but I'm not giving
you any more money.
- Right.
- These kids hear it and they
want moms and dads to still
give them $1,000 Starbucks
card or pay for the gym.
- Nah, you gotta thug it out.
- So people are hearing the
part they wanna hear from me.
That's why so many people
don't fuck with me at first
because I'm putting pressure
on them and they'd go rather
listen to some other bullshit person--
- They wanna be coddled.
- People do not want to be
held accountable, people do not
want to eat shit, people
wanna prove everybody wrong
without doing the work
to prove everybody wrong.
People think I'm not going
to get a job after 22
and put entrepreneur in my
headline and that's the win.
I saw it in Silicon Valley, too.
The win was raising the money.
You grew up in the Genius.
You get it, right?
You saw Twitter 2010
through 15, congratulations,
just like when you left,
congratulations, you've raised
$3 million.
I was like, so.
- That's when the pressure starts
because now you gotta prove
that you're worth that.
- There's a Bloomberg video,
D-rock, I want it fucking
edited in here right now
and this rant, I want it up.
I want the whole fucking thing.
I know you got a lot
of good content today.
I want a lot of it.
I'm on fucking Bloomberg
and everybody's cheering.
It's this fucking tech stars competition
and some dude goes ...
(clapping)
Everyone else was talking a
lot of shit, I raise money,
no, I'm sorry, I raise money,
I raise money, I raise money
and everyone's (clapping)
and dude goes, "We
haven't raised any money.
"We've been making money."
And everyone's quiet and I lose my shit.
I'm like this is why this
whole fucking thing's broken.
Fuck you.
- (laughing) That's funny.
- Gary, let me start off
with you on this, then.
- Thank God.
(laughing)
- Balancing between fundraising
and building your business,
what do you look for in a CEO?
- I'm concerned a little bit
with the culture of celebrating
the fundraise.
My dad taught me that
when you borrow money,
it's the worst day of your life.
So I'm very interested
in the entrepreneurs.
We didn't clap for Red Rover
because they didn't raise
$6 trillion, but I was
sitting here like, good stuff.
I just filtered myself.
(laughing)
What I'm looking for is
people that are not caught up
in the excitement.
Even though I'm a hype man
myself, I like the practicality
of it all, people that
understand how to turn a profit.
At the end of the day, this
is still business, right,
and so I'm looking for
real practical knowledge
of how to actually make money
not necessarily raise it.
- That's crazy.
- It's reversed.
People aren't hearing
the part that matters.
- But the one thing I will say
because I don't want people
to take it ...
I love journalism, too.
I loved working at XXL.
I was part of the staff--
- You ready for this?
- What's up?
- I think you're gonna
still do journalism.
- Absolutely, well, the
plan is not to quit.
- Of course, you don't have to.
The part that people don't understand
is this fucking Internet
thing gave you options.
- Yeah, yeah.
And where I'm at now with the music
is I built a fan base for my journalism,
I built a following.
- In two places, in the B2B and the B2C.
- Yeah.
- You understand?
- The biggest thing you
built was the B2B love.
That's why you understood all the--
- That's why I'm opening at Barclay's.
- Of course.
- Yeah, that's why I'm
opening for Two Chains
at Terminal Five.
I know what it is.
- 100%
- But now it's not wasting
those opportunities.
- Well, listen, you're
not gonna waste them
because you got lucky and
were brought up in a way
to not understand how to waste them.
You just might not be talented enough.
Your thing isn't gonna be wasted.
You weren't coddled and fed.
You were hungry.
You've got the hard part down.
Now, it just depends how talented you are.
Honestly, that's what's kind of cool.
- And that's all you want is a shot.
- 100%
- Look, and this record isn't out yet.
I haven't done any features, yet.
I have a bunch of rap friends
that haven't done any features.
I have a record, it's done.
I'm gonna put it out in a couple of weeks
featuring Styles P.
Styles P to me when you talk
about rap is one of the most
technically skilled rappers around.
- Like the craft.
- Yeah.
I feel like I held my own.
I feel like I got on that record with him
and whether you like my verse
better than his or his verse
better than mines, I belong.
You're gonna hear it and be like, oh, wow.
I see why this is where he's going.
- And that's why you wanted to do it.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- It makes sense.
It's the right strategy.
- Absolutely.
- Even with our playlist,
the reason I just pulled
my phone out, I posted the
playlist like I do every week,
the only comment was
someone wrote Long Fly Home
truly struck me.
Really appreciate you putting me on.
And that's his song.
It was the last song on
our playlist this week
and it's his song and he was
telling me how he wrote it--
- Storytelling.
Listen, man.
Listen, you know me.
I like comic books, episode one.
- I'm a big comic fan.
- Of course you are.
Brother, the only reason
I'm even sitting ...
The only reason I'm
sitting here is because
when Juicy came out, I started
to understand why I liked it.
Because Biggie was painting
such a clear fucking story
in that fucking song and I
at 18 years old was like,
oh, that's what I like.
Up until that point, with
fucking Dr. Dre and Too Short
and fucking Beastie Boys
and Fat Boys and KRS-1,
I didn't know.
I was like, it's cool.
I'm from Edison, it's top,
but that song came out.
I knew exactly what his room looked like.
I knew exactly what was
happening and I was like, (snaps)
And forever my relationship
with the genre changed.
I don't even understand music.
I'm being dead serious.
All these producers and
everything, beats and everything,
I'm like, yes, I understand the thesis of
when Hypnotize comes on
and you hear that ...
I get that, but I don't fuck with it.
- Right, you know what it is?
- I wanna hear what
the person's gonna say.
- Because it's a feeling.
- Again, I understand if
it's off the fucking rocker
and everybody understands
and it comes on and everybody
in the club goes and everyone's dancing.
I understand, but out of
1,000 songs right now,
of really good producers,
I'm not gonna understand 994
of them because they're
just gonna be great.
But what I'm gonna understand
is what people are saying.
Like what Big Chris is trying
to say to me, what Rallo
is saying in that song.
Young Bandz, I fuck with
him because of that.
I like what he's saying, and
he's still a kid and he's got
fucking pain inside of him.
I can hear it.
That's why you're gonna win.
- You know it was funny that you say that.
The record that's on the
Monday to Monday playlist,
Long Flight Home, I was literally in LAX,
my flight got delayed.
I just wanted to be home and
the flight kept getting pushed
back and I was in a foul mood
and my producer had sent me
three beats, so I'm like, let
me just check out these beats.
I checked out the first one,
the first 10 seconds, ugh!
I don't like it.
Second one, first 10 seconds,
ugh, I don't like it.
The beat for Long Flight Home
came on, I think it was called
Winter Story, was the name of
the beat before it was Home.
I played it and I was
like, Holy shit, this beat
is the exact mood that I'm in.
- Let's go.
- So I started writing on
the spot in LAX sitting down
waiting for my plane.
I stopped writing, I looked to
my right and I see a clutch,
a Coach clutch and I pick it
up and "Is this anybody's?"
It's nobody's.
I looked, there's $500 in
there, ID, credit cards.
I'm like, Holy shit.
The old me would've kept that.
I'm from Flatbush Brooklyn.
But I took it to the gate and said,
"Look, somebody left this."
And I'm thinking that's not my shit.
That could be their
student loan, that could be
their car note, whatever.
I sit back down to write the
song and forgot where I was at
so I'm like where do I pick up at?
Oh, I'm gonna pick up
with what just happened.
I found a clutch with five hunnid in it.
Just turned it in at the gate.
And I went from there.
- Listen, look at the fuck I'm doing.
I think that's the number one
thing people should do is tell
the truth and document
the fucking journey.
I don't think ...
Actually, this is actually
to talk to music people,
I think a couple more years,
I'm gonna be really
helping people in music.
Let me explain.
The first project's easy.
- Got your whole life to write it.
You got a life's worth of stories.
- You got it.
My first keynote, of
course it was perfect.
I'm like, I'm a boy from Belarus.
I wrote a fucking ...
Like Lemonade and it hit.
It hit.
It hit because it was easy.
I didn't realize, of course I
didn't have slides, of course
I was spitting from the top.
I was just telling you who the fuck I was
and what I was thinking about.
But I told you what I was
for the first 20 minutes
and the reason they all
fucked with me after a while
because there's only so
many times you can hear
about the baseball cards, was
and then I told you about
what was happening right now.
And so to me a lot of artists
kill that first project
and they become one hit wonders
or one project superstars
because they don't realize
they wanna tell a story
which means they're making up shit.
- Right.
- But what they need to tell
you is what the fuck happened
when you made the
transition from the streets
to the businessman trying
to negotiate with you?
- I'll tell you.
In that song, Long Flight
Home, let's talk about
because of my relationships
when I dropped my first EP
last year and I signed
with Empire Distribution,
everybody expected me to
have a bunch of features
because I had a great relationship.
I didn't want a bunch of features--
- Because you thought strategically.
I got it.
- But I'm gonna keep it real.
There were some guys
that I asked for features
who didn't take me seriously.
And they just fueled some of the fire.
I never wanted to admit that
because it made me feel like
if I admitted it, I was lesser.
- No, you're more, you're more.
That's me.
I'm driven ...
All I want is negative comments.
- Right, it drives you.
- I love that.
The funniest thing is the
people that give me love
in this comment section, I love them.
I love them like I love my mother, right?
But the people that leave
me negative comments,
they don't realize they think
they're tearing me down,
you're fucking feeding
me, you motherfucker.
You're feeding me.
You're fucking feeding--
- (laughs) You fucking haters.
- You're so not smart.
Actually, I only feel two things.
You're so not smart, you're
feeding me, I'm gonna get bigger
and badder because of what
you're doing and then number two
I feel bad for you.
You really have so much pain
in your life that you've taken
time out of being on the offense
to come to me and tell me
something bad?
I hate that.
Your mom fucked up.
Something happened.
- I feel the same way.
I really feel bad for those people.
- I apologize for cutting
you off, the one weird thing
about me that I'm ...
The thing about me that
probably the culture likes,
the thing that's weird with me though is
if I were you, if I was living
your exact life right now,
after I was accepted as that skilled,
I would destroy those fuckers on wax.
And I mean in a fun, because
they're your friends,
in a fun way.
I'm very chippy.
- Fuck them.
I'm ready, too.
I'm not really a battle type of guy.
I'm more of a storyteller
but this is hip hop
and it's competitive
and it's a bloodsport--
- Oh, God, that's the best.
That's the best.
- I'm ready.
- I'm always ready, too, but
honestly, unlike what you did
there, I'm keeping it
all inside, all of it.
And the truth is I keep it
inside because the good news is
99.9% of it goes away.
But man do I feel bad for those .1.
Because their feelings
would be hurt forever.
(laughing)
I'm trying to do generational hurt.
- We over here trying to do
generational wealth, Gary,
not generational hurt.
(laughing)
- I was just thinking about
the .1, there's two or three
people on a list and their
kids are gonna get hurt.
(laughing)
But you know me, it's
because doing the wrong thing
is the wrong thing.
- Oh, yeah.
- That's never the answer.
- Honestly, there used to
be seven people on the list,
but enough time went on ...
My hope is that it never happens.
- It goes away?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Number one thing I tell about you
is that you had a really good heart.
That's what I always tell
everyone, you know what I mean?
Yeah, they must've really messed up.
- You know what it is,
I'm just competitive
and the main thing for me is just
it's really funny, I could actually now,
I'm gonna talk it out for real.
I'll never do it.
How many times have you
seen me hurt somebody?
- Never.
- It's just not in me.
- It's okay, honey, we'll talk about it.
It was just one night.
- It's on the shelf and it feeds me
because I wanna stick
it in people's mouth.
The greatest feeling is the look.
There's been plenty of times in business
when somebody's looked at
me and I've looked at them
and we know the exact story that happened.
Seven years ago, you punked me
and said I wasn't gonna be shit.
I fucking crushed and three
years ago, I fucking helped
your sister and one year
ago, you acknowledged it
subliminally and now we're
both looking at each other
and I'm like, see, I'm
a bigger man than you,
you fucking ...
I'm a bigger man than you.
- I just caught Tupac vibes.
(laughing)
- Or when Gary speaks and
they spell his name wrong,
that's probably something
you're gonna go through.
You're doing a show and
they fuck up something
about your set--
- Boyd I saw a video yesterday
- that VaynerMedia made
that I'm in, they spelled my name wrong.
(laughing)
- I was at a keynote, he's like,
"They spelled my name wrong
"on this thing and I will
destroy the whole competition."
And everybody was standing
ovation at the end of the show.
Complex time.
- Yeah, man.
- I like it.
- I appreciate where you come from, man,
and in a lot of ways my EP
was called Write to Dream
and because I'm a writer, I
started out as a journalist
so it's W-R-I-T-E to Dream.
But the real message is I have
a right to dream, you have
a right to dream, you have a
right to dream and nobody has
the right to tear you down.
- My man, do you know why it
matters the most right now
and why I'm putting out so much shit?
If you were writing
for the Source in 1994,
if you were literally born 20
years earlier and were writing
for the Source, you wouldn't
be in the music industry today
because you would have to get signed,
the end.
Empire and Spotify and YouTube,
people don't get it.
A right to dream was
aspirational and ideological
50 years ago.
It's just not anymore.
That's crazy.
Honestly, I can't believe
that fucking a kid right now
is gonna get hyped off of
this, record on his phone,
on her phone, upload it to SoundCloud
and sell out fucking Madison
Square Garden in nine years.
- Because we've seen it.
And the one thing that I
can tell you, thankfully I'm
in a position because of the journalism,
I don't have to monetize the music.
- I got it.
- I want to monetize the
music and I want to grow it
as a business, but I don't
wanna skip any steps.
- I get it.
- So I'm building a base.
So money is not really an
issue, it's for the love.
But the most rewarding
thing more than a check
and I've gotten a couple
checks off the ratchet,
it's cool, but the most rewarding thing--
- The love, the love.
That verse ...
Yeah.
Who're you talking to?
That's all I've defaulted into.
- Right.
And you know they always say
people might not remember
exactly what you said to them,
but they'll always remember
how you made them feel?
- Maya Angelou.
- Yeah, so whoever writes that book,
whoever becomes the next
big rapper, whoever becomes
the next big journalist,
they're never gonna forget
who inspired them and
you're part of that network.
- My man, it's the only
thing I think about.
I absolutely know I will be
the greatest entrepreneur
this era because I'm gonna
win on the two fronts
that people are gonna judge by.
I'll make enough money so
that I'm in the conversation
and I will fucking inspire
and help more entrepreneurs
than the rest of the field combined.
I'm talking all them.
Because what Elon Musk does
in his actions to inspire
is incredible.
It's incredible.
And Steve Jobs ...
But what I'm doing is different
and I know it.
And by the way, it's
because I want it more.
It's not that I'm better.
I just want that.
That's the part I want.
It's what this whole thing is.
People don't even understand
what I'm actually doing.
From a businessman's standpoint,
I'm leaving so much money
on the table.
- Right, but money is not the goal.
- No, you know what's funny for me,
money stopped being the goal at $100,000.
I couldn't believe I made $100,000 a year.
I was like ...
That was it.
And since then, nothing's been the same.
Doesn't feel the same, not
a million, not 10 million,
it doesn't feel the same.
$100,000.
Five bucks,
see this, see this scar?
I was the ring boy in a relative's wedding
and Jewish people step on the glass.
I was the oldest of the kids,
I was nine, everyone else
was six and five.
I was the alpha, running
everybody around being ridiculous.
I was like, "Yo, let's go find the glass."
I found it.
I went and grab it, cut
the shit out of my hand.
We were still pretty poor
back then, like real poor,
lower middle class and my dad
gave me five bucks to go home
with my great grandmother
because I didn't want to leave.
That was the best day of my life.
(laughing)
I've never told that story.
I looked at that five dollar
bill my whole life, I think.
For six years, I looked at it.
It felt like so much.
- Right.
- Now, I don't even know how to ...
Because ATMs don't give
anything less than 20,
you know this,
I tip 20 for everything
and it's real funny
because I don't want to.
I think 10 is more applicable sometimes.
I'm not the best guy ever but
I just don't have them on me.
(laughing)
- You gotta go to the hood
ATMs and get the five, 10s.
- Yeah, man.
(laughing)
- Time for me to go?
Alright, I gotta bounce.
- Thank you for this, man.
- Yeah man, listen, keep hitting us up.
We wanna give love.
I'm very fascinated by ...
I love the track.
- I appreciate it, thank you--
- Loved it and I so saw the storytelling,
you know?
- Thank you.
- I just wanted to make
you feel something.
I wanted to just make
you to feel something.
(upbeat music)